the online retail giant Amazon face
walkouts around the globe as the holiday
shopping season got underway last week
thousands of workers including some here
in the U.S staged protests to demand
better pay and working conditions CBS
News has reached out to Amazon multiple
times but they have yet to respond all
of this comes amid projections that this
year's Cyber Monday could generate check
this number out more than 11 billion
dollars in online sales so that's up
more than five percent from last year
although inflation could be a factor
Nancy Chen is at an Amazon fulfillment
center in New Jersey with an inside look
at how those Cyber Monday orders get
right to your doorstep Nancy good
morning
hey good morning to you Nate yeah that's
right it may be early but Cyber Monday
is clearly in full swing here and you
ever wonder how one of these packages
gets to your doorstep after you check
out well that question let us to
Washington State we visited one of the
largest fulfillment centers in the world
[Music]
with just a few clicks it sometimes
seems like almost anything can show up
at your doorstep within days it's not
hours but how it gets there from here is
a journey for some 22 million items that
can include nearly 5 000 robots and
thousands of people at this facility
alone it seems like this really is a 24
7 operation it is Evan shobe oversees
Amazon's Flagship fulfillment center
near the company's Seattle headquarters
how to all come together what I like to
categorize is a 3 000 person jazz band
so we're constantly reacting to a change
in Tempo or Rhythm uh that are coming
together to bring a lot of diverse
products into the building worldwide
Amazon ships over 66 000 orders every
hour and it all starts at one of 400
warehouses like this controlled by
robots these bins hold everything you
might buy and move around as orders come
in an employee then picks up those
purchases so they can travel on these
conveyor belts to be packed
the belts which stretched nearly 18
miles when laid back to back then carry
toads to packing stations when the toad
comes to each Packer they're taking the
tote down they scan each item the
software tells them which of these many
boxes is the perfect box for that item a
combination of technology and the human
touch Amazon is still aiming to hire a
hundred and fifty thousand workers both
seasonal and Beyond as it rips up
Staffing for the holidays this as the
company plans to lay off thousands of
corporate employees with Amazon CEO
signaling that more reductions will be
coming in the new year but the online
giant says its holiday orders won't be
affected how many orders does Amazon
process each day you know it can vary
but in this facility we can process up
to a million packages and items in a
24-hour period 04 at Boca leads human
resources for Amazon's Global operations
and says they're ready to take on the
holiday shopping season in our
operations we are prepared and we
believe we're going to deliver on behalf
of our customers in the time frame that
they need you know we are also hearing
about potential shipping delays
elsewhere should we be prepared for any
delays from Amazon you know we've been
preparing all year long for our shipping
our and investing in our Network and our
transportation our delivery so we're
excited and we're ready with the boxes
that delivery takes
it then the packages are trucked down
the street to a second Warehouse a
delivery station where they'll be loaded
onto Vans like these with this much at
stake every square inch on one of these
Vans could mean big bucks as drivers
like Paulo Ibanez stack boxes so no room
is wasted is it like a game of Tetris
absolutely once once you start putting
all the packages inside between the
totes and the boxes it does become a
game of Tetris to be able to fit
everything in the van a game of puzzles
as every piece falls into place
and Amazon says it expects this year's
Cyber Monday event to be even bigger
than the record-breaking one they had
last year the national retail Federation
anticipates nearly 64 million people
will shop online and in stores this
Cyber Monday and hey Tony if any of
these boxes are yours let me know and
I'll grab it for you on my way back I
don't know they're moving pretty fast
it's an amazing story wow a million
boxes a day thank you very much times
have changed since Nate worked at a
early Amazon book delivery service
that's right 90s Nate that's right late
90s coming up the story look at him
today at the cinema this morning's table
see what happens when you start like
that very good Nate but I'm stuck with
Jeff should have made an investment
that's for sure